Oh God that was a horrible intro I'm
sorry that is rude well we found a key
over here call there's something in the
round what is this a present for me
who said that don't you dare be that ah
I hate that [ __ ]
but ya thought brother can I have it she
gave to me right rough it's Myra
it's Pharaoh's [ __ ] get back Mary
oh and did you find what you were
looking but anyway look it I just got
that Freddie's in it Mary that that rose
huh oh you mean this Apes I thought I
said it Mary please give that back to em
huh I wonder yes Scott well hmm
want to trade Gary's what
I like blue even more see this dolls
blue - no she's not
so wanna tree ah no don't give me that
look yet don't worry it'll be fine just
leave it to me
got it understood please give me ABS
rose in exchange for my really sure yes
pretty pretty flower be careful with it
I'm sorry why are you polish get in and
anything rocket right so they're like so
now and my rose well we'll just catch
Mary and get it so let's do our best
and I don't we're almost what what what
is with these ghetto you became oh [ __ ]
come on I really have to do that all
that again [ __ ] me it's dark - yes loves
me
no no no loves me not loves me
Gary I'm sorry but no no no no no I'm
not going with that Gary I go without
you know ah Gary I'd bench what bad for
what your dad I can hardly turn these
yes
finally Yosh it's okay
she went south oh she's coming back of
course my diet I why and how did you get
into this room you can't can't be here
please leave now now now ah [ __ ] come on
stop killing me
whoa that was in last second uh remove
it it won't come I thought your [ __ ]
[ __ ] burn it
oh it's where she came from
ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what you get
I should we got a check on Gary let's go
back and check on Gary Steve's okay
let's say Gary you better be here Gary
I'm sorry he's sleeping
all of the fine what about this pink
what is this [ __ ] why am I going here ha
ha ha oh my god
oh we're about here well what the [ __ ]
uh maybe we should go back to the
Abbott's where we like started all this
[ __ ] all right that's so [ __ ] this
painting
what what today their paintings chase ah
ah we're going back
ah yeah is he safe huh Gary you better
[ __ ] yeah it's not here it's already
want to shake that go I know you were a
good kid all right let's go we're at it
whatever I'll bring up the automatic
just [ __ ] yeah
ah feels good Hollis party Gary's gonna
die that's it awesome ha game ok game
kinda pissed me off with a puzzle in the
end but damn this is good game for a
free fruit group my god we got the best
ending grass hikvision guys let's play
subscribe to compress me and I'll see
you next episode on grammar
la mer is you gotta be shy riding here
hey wait your eyes open ah let's go we
could get along this is not right listen